jojo was geht und herzlich willkommen zu
meinem heutigen video ihr seht schon ich
bin draußen und das hat einen ganz
bestimmten grund sicherlich kennt ihr
diese habe boards self balancing
scooters oder wie auch immer man es
nennen mag hama hat mir so ein ding
zugeschickt und das ding ist das ist
nicht irgendwie so irgendein scooter
sondern das ding soll verdammt sicher
sein produkt in germany designed in
germany develop in germany abruft in
germany die garantieren dass nicht
irgendwie der akku in die luft fliegt
oder sowas
so wie es das ja schon öfters mal gab
bei solchen dingern es war außerdem mega
präzise in der linken sein und wenn der
akku leer ist dann fällt man nicht
irgendwie runter so wie das manchmal ist
sondern das brems- und soll ganz gut
sein das ding was ich hier habe ist die
outdoor version also die cross version
und ich habe einen parcours aufgebaut
mit dem ich das ding testen werde und
weil das logischerweise langweilig wäre
so ein parcours alleine zu machen habe
ich mir im kumpel ins boot geholt und
zwar sebi den kennt ihr wahrscheinlich
nicht weil er kein youtube macht aber
der ist ziemlich gut mit solchen sachen
und ich habe angst zu verlieren
gleich darauf ankommen wer von uns
beiden den parcours am schnellsten
absolvieren kann es beginnt erstmal mit
einem klassischen parcours aber trotzdem
vorsicht der rasen ist schon ziemlich
nass und das wird sie mich rusching aber
später wird es noch ein bisschen
rutschig
dann wird hier vom fahrenden hava dort
aus werden drei flaschen umgestoßen eine
rikscha danach erst weiterfahren wenn
alle flaschen liegen bzw wenn die
patronen leer sind und dann kommen wir
zu dieser strecke die erst mal
unscheinbar aussieht das ding ist wir
haben hauptspiel die drüber gemacht das
ding ist sauer rutschig und hier muss
man die kurve kriegen
auf dem rückenteil dann ein sprint stück
nach vorne und dann gehts darauf auch
auf dem cover bord den ball zu versenken
erst wenn getroffen ist wird die zeit
gestoppt so wir haben auch was
vorbereitet für den verlierer von diesem
parcours und zwar ist das nichts
geringeres als ein gottverdammte eimer
voll mit lieber schleier über den kopf
vom verlierer froh dass wir zu hart ob
das mal an gustavo wort wir fahren uns
ein bisschen ein dann geht's los
es ist schwierig auf der wiese zu fahren
aber das macht uns ein parcours noch
lustiger so leute wie ist jetzt am start
da vorne beginnt red back uhr nochmal
zur erinnerung es ist erst vorbei wenn
du den ball versenkt haft
geht doch
überlegt an nicht zu schnell gelöst
für jeden fall 17 sekunden
jetzt warten noch ganz an
klopp
ok 22 minuten ohne ein feiner geboten
wird hier die ecke da nicht so schnell
fahren am besten gar nicht rüber
ok oder fiel schnell das ging schnell
nicht gut an baby im endspurt
mein erster versuch nicht gekommen
die sind fast einer minute so gibt es
zuschüsse für das isländische
runtergefahren einige stunden das gibt
den roten bogen
die personen an bord
mata
nein pocher geb ich auch nicht so schwer
wie es aussieht leute oder ist das
trink- und starb zwei minuten 2
wie wirst du zufrieden mit seiner
leistung
ohne misst also damit sofort ist
eigentlich recht frisch und so weiter
arbeit mit den unebenheiten weil es zu
nass sind das problem trixi wenigen
klicks und da jeder lust zum ersten
sektor den slalom parcours
ja im glück
london
jetzt muss man dabei 17
immerhin ein buch
dennoch das coaching
berlin
und fertig 59
format den schleim duschen wird
aber es war die extrem träsch und ich
bin also leute ich war ein bisschen
schneller als sie aber ihr seht dass
mein atem verschlägt sie wenn ich jetzt
weniger bock den schein über kopf
einkommen macht einfach was bringt der
wird es teurer als erstes wird hier mal
der gewinner gefeiert
ihr seht hier den sieger dafür jetzt
kommen wir zu sehen
so leute wir haben hier den eimer voll
mit schleim müsste bereit
das ist voll gut weil das nicht nass
macht wie war das baby noch ein bisschen
schleim überhäuft oben rücken
mal wieder mit mir hast du dich deutlich
verlegt euch mal wie instagram danke dir
folgen falls ihr ferne zwar lustig wie
er verloren hat
ich fand es ziemlich lustig ehrlich
gesagt noch ein paar letzte worte sowie
haben jetzt fertig gedreht und
aufgeräumt und die grünen jetzt einfach
noch so ein bisschen rum auf den asphalt
und sonstwas und wir checken raus auf
jeden fall cool shots kriegen und männer
das ding wird so schnell auf was wald
und by the way leute wenn man bremst mit
dem gerät lädt sich die batterie wieder
auf das heißt ihr könnt so oder so schon
18 kilometer fahren und wenn ihr dann
berg und erfahrt könnt ihr im prinzip
unendlich war ok go see browser
abonniert frank schäffler
franken
so leute das war's vom heutigen videos
hat mir unendlich viel spaß gemacht
wirklich also es war eine extrem coole
kooperation ist wahrscheinlich im video
sehen dass sie voll van hatte beim
drehen und sonst was ich habe auch noch
gute nachrichten für euch und zwar könnt
ihr eines von diesen hammer boards
gewinnen dazu packe ich euch noch mal
ein link unten in die beschreibung alle
infos wie ihr teilnehmen könnt und
sonstwas findet ihr wenn ihr auf den
link drauf klickt danke hammer für die
coole kooperation und den link zum
normalen bord findet ihr auch nochmal
unten
dann sehen wir uns bald wieder macht's
gut